c'est un problème important pour lille 1
mais nous ne résoudrons alors françois
que décidez-vous
j'hésite secteur c'est vraiment une
chose importante
moi je trouve que tu devrais accepter
parce que président de la fête annuelle
de l'île aux enfants dedans ça fait
drôlement sérieux quand pour sûr et
c'est même un titre très honorifique au
facteur savez très bien que les honneurs
ne m'intéresse pas tellement non et puis
je voudrais pas gêner la candidature de
monsieur du snob qui a tellement envie
d'être président de l'afep c'est bien
mais ça n'avait pas encore dit mais si
c'est pour en avoir envie vous savez il
en a envie j'ai entendu dire qu'il sait
déjà comment des nouveaux chapeaux et un
nouveau costume tellement il est sûr
d'être élu décidément nos je pars je
préfère renoncer si jamais j'étais élu
la peine de monsieur snob ne gâcherait
tout mes joueurs autant raison parce
qu'au fond il a peu agaçant comme ça
mais il est très sérieux et très honnête
est-ce qu'il a des chances d'être élu ou
c'est le candidat le mieux placé vous
savez un tenait mademoiselle
mademoiselle verado ap le choc de cette
gracieuse live vous gâcherait tout la
fête ou pour sûr mais il ya aussi le
gardien du port et mille feuilles mais
drogba et ben je suis sûr qu'il est ce
13 ans pour avoir la plus grosse teuf
dit gâteau que lui voue j'avais toujours
le mot pour rire
indoor vous trouvez que c'est bien de
dire du mal de tout le monde
si vous le prenez comme ça j'arrête de
vous lire la liste des candidats de
toute façon moi je vote pour monsieur 10
9 mars mais je crois que je lui donnerai
aussi ma voix rien que pour le spectacle
voilà casimir qui arrive or je crois
qu'il vaut mieux changer de sujet 1 si
jamais il apprend par monsieur dix neuf
ans et candidat pour la présidence de la
fête il va absolument vouloir lui aussi
être président
qu'est ce que vous disiez au sujet de
monsieur du synode crois que tu as parlé
trop fort je comprendrai jamais comment
plaisir peut avoir leur you seen alors
qu'il n'en a pas
qu'est ce qui se passe toujours quelque
oui mais non que tenir on est en train
d'inventer un nouveau jeu pour les
enfants bon mais à propos de monsieur du
snob un
bonjour bonjour j'utilise ged casimir je
m'excuse pendant que j'y pense tu n'as
pas une lettre à me donner pour poster
non un facteur mais vous parliez de
mouzillon casimir que si j'arrive à tim
angers bon gloubiboulga hier soir vous
me prenez pour un imbécile je sens que
je vais me mettre en colère casimir tu
te calmes et tu vas me donne même pas de
métro colère par casimir ne suit pas ça
un bon mais alors au à propos de
monsieur liste nos blessés c'est sans
importance
je sens commun colère moa non non non
mon vieux
bon bon bon bah écoute casimir tu as
gagné moi je gagne toujours bon alors à
propos de monsieur d'isnor rien il se
présente aux élections pour être élu
président de la fête annuelle de l'île
aux enfants au suffrage universel au au
nom alors sa
transe war qu'est ce que çà et là
comment appelez-vous ça le suffrage
universel bon eh bien ça veut dire que
tous les habitants de l'île ont le droit
de voter
c'est à dire que tout le monde dans
l'île peut voter exactement on dit les
grandes les bons et les méchants les
gros comme le facteur les [ __ ] les
gens riches les pauvres que ce soit les
gens importants ou pas dans le suffrage
universel
tout le monde a le droit de voter et le
vote de chaque personne a la même
importance par exemple bien qu'ils aient
mis un en france eh ben c'est comme ça
qu'on élit le président de la république
et les députés bon mais fait les enfants
aussi là en france pour avoir le droit
de voter il faut au moins avoir 18 ans
parce que il faut bien comprendre ce que
c'est que la politique non métis suri
nos enfants pour l'élection de la fête
par l'île aux enfants tous les enfants
doivent voter bon d'accord
excuse moi je vais vérifier quelque
chose
là là j'ai bien peur que casimir ne
commence déjà sa campagne électorale
facteur oui casimir à vous même et bien
avant pour sûr bon et quand est ce que
vous ma préférée tu le sais bien oui
encore plus quand tu danses pendant ta
chanson ah oui comme ça
comme ça là mon vieux je t'adore
merci-facteur
julie oui dis moi je dis tu me préfère
comme ça
ou alors
comme ça pas de n'importe quelle façon
de toute façon tu es vous préférez alors
je t'aime de toutes les façons merci
raison forme ecoutez-la écouter les
enfants est-ce que vous m'aimez bien
ouais bon merci merci bien
didot quasi mais ça s'est bien passé je
suis
un petit peu essoufflé mais ça s'est
très bien passé là bas tant mieux dis
moi oui est ce que je peux te poser une
question avec les héros qu'est ce que
c'est que la le maltage à le ballottage
est bien aux 10 à l'ours qu'aucun des
candidats n'a obtenu la majorité absolue
à dire plus de la moitié des votes on
doit alors voter une deuxième fois tu
veux bien me répéter ça je te répète
casimir on dit cela lors ce qu'aucun des
candidats n'a obtenu la majorité absolue
c'est à dire plus de la moitié des votes
on doit alors rejeté une deuxième fois
bon d'accord d'accord
pardon
écoutez moi
écoutez moi tout ce
modèle je suis candidat à l'élection de
la fête du président à l'île aux enfants
quoique tu veux vraiment te présenter à
l'élection ouais j'ai décidé de mettre
ce ballot de monsieur du snob en
ballottage
[Applaudissements]
voilà la laponie ses caramels là ils
sont très bien
savez vous bien pili proposant
diverses un peu de ceci servez vous
prenez en plein
sahel c'est quoi aujourd'hui élection du
président de la fête de l'île aux
enfants
mais c'est parfait sur celle là non plus
il n'y a pas de fautes d'orthographe à
un facteur 4 casimir
vous voulez que je vous fasse une petite
danse
et pourquoi tout à coup tu veux me faire
une petite danse
vous savez quand je suis candidat à la
présidence de la fête de l'île aux
enfants pour sûr même qu'il n'y a plus
que toi et monsieur du snob les autres
candidats se sont retirés il avait peur
de trop ridicule ouais ben ils ont eu
raison
monsieur du snop aurait bien fait dans
père au top on me dit non tu as bien
versions de toit ouais parce que j'ai eu
une grande idée à bout et laquelle
casimir j'ai promis à tout le monde de
faire ce qui lui plairait s'ils votent
pour moi
alors vous par exemple je vous ferai
tous les jours une petite danse comme ça
va t'en va pas par nous pas me tam tam
papa papa pas rentable voilà bravo
j'adore te voir danser casimir mais tu
es quand même un drôle de démagogues
allez allez mon vieux qu'il faut que je
me dépêche j'ai encore beaucoup d'
affiches apposées au revoir casimir un
facteur et qu'est ce que c'est que ça et
il m'a traitée de démagogues qu'est ce
que c'est c'est c'est gentil où c'est
méchant
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous les
enfants
dits magog vous savez ce que c'est vous
croyez
reprenez des bonbons reprenait des
bonbons vous savez les enfants si vous
votez pour moi vous aurez tous les jours
des bonbons des nougats des caramels du
chocolat tout ça gratuit et bien
kazimierz et joyeux pour moi ce que tu
promets là tu veux ma perte pourquoi
julie mon mon programme électoral ne te
convient pas tu veux que je te donne
aussi des bonbons mais tu sais bien que
je gagne ma vie en vendant des bonbons
des chocolats et des caramels ouais et
alors alors si tu en distribuer
gratuitement je ne pourrai plus vendre
les miens je n'ai plus qu'à partir j'en
ai pas pensé à ça mais j'ai une idée
écoute je distribuerai les bonbons
gratuitement les bons mots je t'aurais
acheter
mais si tu avais beaucoup d'argent ça
sera une très bonne solution pour moi
mais ça ressemble fort à une promesse de
démagogues kouakou kouao si tu me prêtes
de démagogues où est mon vieux à tout à
l'heure il faut que j'ouvre mon casque
aux
démagogues démago que j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que ça veut dire nous vous
avez une idée vous lorsque c'est
assez embêtant
c'est vraiment embêtant pas savoir allez
les enfants reprenaient plein de bonbons
un servez vous bien mettez en plaire aux
poches
voilà bonjour casimir quoi qu'est-ce que
ça ira françois comment se passe sa
campagne électorale bien bien mais je
voudrais qu'on habille je t'écoute
apaisé voilà regarde moi je te regarde
non mais regardez moi bien
mieux que ça mais j'étais parfaitement
regardes et tu n'as remarque que rien
non non a alors je ne suis pas
d'hématome
m'écoute casimir ça ne se voit pas sur
le visage de quelqu'un quand il est
démagogue c'est uniquement une façon
d'agir
ah bon parce que julie que le facteur
montrer qu'ee de démagogues et je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire écoute
casimir écoute moi bien
on dit de quelqu'un qu'il était magog
lorsqu'il essaie d'être élu ou
simplement de se faire bien voir par
tout le monde en promettant des choses
qui pourra pas tenir par exemple offrir
des bravos et des chocolats à tous les
enfants du jardin tous les jours c'est
pas toi qui fais quelque chose d'aussi
mâle noir n'ont sûrement pas à faire
simple on m'écoute il faut que je m'en
aille j'ai deux ou trois choses à faire
avant d'aller voter att leurs actes
alors jour casimir à bonjour monsieur du
snab l'heure décisive approche ce tout
le monde quitte le jardin pour aller
voter non bon vent monsieur douce nab au
oui je sais mais j'aurais du mal à
gagner l'élection tu as fait une
campagne électorale de démagogues on
vous a dit ça oui mais je connais au
moins une fois que tu n'auras pas quoi
la mienne paix mais mais mais pourquoi
enfin vous devez voter pour moi je vous
promets de faire tout ce que vous voulez
si vous votez pour moi je ne peux te
croire au futur du club je vous le
promets c'est très simple casimir je
voterai pour toi si tu retires ta
candidature c'est tout oui je voterai
pour toi mais c'est formidable quand j'y
vais j'y vais j'y vais je vais retirer
ma candidature
je crois que cette fois ci et casimir a
été trop démagogue
puisqu'il retire sa candidature personne
ne votera pour lui personne sauf moi
bien sûr qu'est ce que j'ai promis
bravo bravo cher
encore une fois mon cher président
toutes mes félicitations c'est mon ami
merci beaucoup j'ai hâte de voir le
nouveau estime que vous êtes acheter
quoi je crois tu ne feras pas les chers
amis j'aimerais quand même bien savoir
ce qui a décidé casimir a retiré sa
candidature et à vous laisser la
victoire
sauriez-vous quelque chose au moins est
vraiment je n'en ai pas la moindre idée
le tout cas heureusement pour vous qu il
l'a fait parce que je n'aurais pas eu le
courage de voter contre lui je comprends
très bien chère julie
côté ce n'était pas la peine j'étais sur
les prêts lui j'ai été chercher mon
chapeau le président il est beau n'est
ce pas je vais faire un très beau
président mais enfin casimir tu a retiré
sa candidature
ouais et alors tu sais ce que ça veut
dire oui n'ont enfin pas très bien que
tu ne voulait plus qu'on vote pour toi
que je ne voulais plus être président
alors on enlever tous les bulles taton
non il ne restait plus que ceux de
monsieur du snam et tout le monde a voté
pour lui ah bon que l'on ne se fout moi
j'ai tenu ma promesse
à jeu vient d'examiner les bulletins de
vote monsieur du snop bien sûr est élu
mais casimir a une voix
la mienne comme promis
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai été un peu trop
démagogue haut que juni